aussi je suis du togo au contraire ça me
fait très plaisir
et toi tu viens d'où tu peux pas conne
xtrac êtes ici aujourd'hui parce que
vous allez du potentiel et tous du
talent mais le talent ça suffit pas
tangent bon tu t'es cru ou là les
gazelles qui réussissait pas une école
sans c'est clair marché elle va alors
qu'est ce tu nous fais c'est pas une
soirée cosby show à bouger pas les faits
je vois là vous battez pas je passe le
valide puisque tu veux que - moi je
pense qu'on attaque l'impression qu'on a
un nouveau produit je parle je souffrais
bien devait prendre tous ces gens
montent tout blanc répète ça ne suffit
pas les 12 heures quotidien pour moi il
faut croire que non c'est pas le moment
de relâcher la pression il faut que tu
seras prêt à tout sacrifier cela
tu mènes ouais je vois pas pas pris un
coup quoi mais tous vos mails des
titulaires du parti nouveau ici
pensez vraiment je peux te faire
confiance des parents nos cousins j'ai
rien dit à personne alors je t'écoute
bucaspor
c'est pas toi qui m'as nick mallett a de
singulier je n'ai jamais été aussi
proche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
m
[Musique]